park mgm is giving former golden knights
player ryan reeves a sin city send off
before he leaves for new york city it's
not goodbye it's see you later party
tonight at 7. j.c fernandez joining us
live from park mgm with a full preview
of this big event jc
hey brian yeah it's a party down here
it's a send-off to ryan reeves and
here's how the evening works you come
down here you check in you'll get a
little you get a little ticket and if
you're over 21 you also get a sample of
ryan's beer you check in you get in line
and you're gonna get an autograph from
ryan reeves fans started lining up today
at about three o'clock to get stuff
signed and look at this
ryan's gonna be happy when he sees this
ladies you live in las vegas but you're
rangers fans yes we are yes we are it's
a send-off for ryan but are welcome for
us so we're out here to give him a
welcome i think he'll be the first
rangers fans that he sees especially in
las vegas all right so work your way
down the line this is really cool
because tonight if you can't make the
autograph signing there's a party at the
the speakeasy off the record and that
starts at 10 30 tonight so there's a
party with ryan reeves and
someone told me that maybe some other
members of our vegas golden knights
might be there at the party tonight i
don't know so check this out so this guy
over here look what he's got what did
you bring to get signed you brought a
blackjack table huh blackjack table from
the stardust uh we've got penn and
teller carrot top donnie marie terry
fader signing we're to try to get all
the vegas misfits from the first season
first base is dedicated to the first
national team we had here beautiful
ryan will sign anything tonight this guy
here got it line at three o'clock he's
got his kids ready to meet ryan reese
now here so once you get your ticket you
wait in line and ryan will be here to
sign stuff real fast so i you can bring
one item so i
i found a rookie card that i want to get
signed he'll sign that and then
i was looking for some other stuff and
i'm gonna see if i'll sign this and then
maybe hopefully
ryan reeves will sign this for me if
ryan reeves signs this i'm gonna make
big money on ebay i'll send it back to
you guys in the studio
you could make two bucks off that j.c
but thank you for the kind and false
words